a claim actor only just survived the
Rana Plaza collapse she spent hours
trapped under the rubble of the
eight-story building she says she only
received one thousand dollars in
compensation money that has long since
gone
my hands are practically disabled my
hips are damaged and I also have serious
mental trauma I need constant medication
I can't work and need financial help
International labor convention rules
entitled injured Factory workers to
Lifetime compensation something that
hasn't happened in this case
lifetime compensation and Medical Care
along with full Rehabilitation and more
importantly we want those responsible to
be brought to Justice immediately
campaigners say safety has improved
under a new international Accord but
Global Brands need to do more for
workers rights and pay a recent study by
Scotland's Aberdeen University found
many were still using unfair practices
during the pandemic including paying
less than the cost of production
campaigners also want to remove
obstacles to forming unions
it has been 10 years now and the victims
and their families hardly got any
compensation yet we want lifetime
compensation of forty eight thousand
dollars for each injured dead and
missing workers family and we also want
trade unions immediately
well the tragedy
holding a signaling Hammer reacted by
the Bangladesh Workers Party the Rana
Plaza has become an international symbol
of inequality and workers exploitation
across the globe industry experts have
called for governments where clothing
brands are based to force them to stop
unfair purchasing practices and
guarantee the rights of the people who
make their products Bangladesh